the jurgen experience so
in the 1930s from 1935 to 1942 or 43
they did a series of studies i think it
was in sheffield england i've got the
study i can show you
and they had conscientious objectors to
the war and they had them
take different amounts of vitamin c to
see how long it would take to get scurvy
and doses as low as 10 milligrams of
vitamin c per day could prevent scurvy
they experimented with conscientious
objections yeah yeah wow yeah that's
kind of creepy
10 milligrams a day there it is yeah
10 experience carried out in sheffield
unconscientious subjectors to military
service
and if you scroll down to the next page
jamie that's kind of creepy you'll see
the doses
yeah there was um
10 milligrams of vitamin c will prevent
scurvy
right but obviously that's not an
optimum level for health
well we don't know no yeah because if
you look at the um
if you look at the the amount of vitamin
c
they should they say there that between
the 70 milligram group and the 10
milligram group
there was no difference in clinical
outcomes the prevailing thinking is at
10 milligrams is not enough for optimal
health but
we don't actually know there are rolls
of vitamin c beyond the formation of
collagen which is the main
thing that gets broken when we see
scurvy or at least that's the physical
manifestations you get bleeding gums
your teeth fall out this is all
collagenous tissue
the connective tissue in the human body
starts to break down because you can't
hydroxylate
proline residues on the collagen
molecule but
when you look at it beyond that there's
actually some pretty good studies i'll
see if i can
find one i've definitely got one in here
that shows that if you look at people
eating
they did another experiment with excess
fruits and vegetables
and they had one group that had small
amounts of fruits and vegetables
and now we're going to skip up to 70
milligrams so it's a little bit more
than 10. there's no experiments with
like long-term 10 milligrams of vitamin
c per day
but there's an experiment that compares
70 milligrams of vitamin c per day from
low fruits and vegetables
to 270 milligrams of fruits and
vegetables 250 milligrams of vitamin c
from fruits and vegetables
and there were no clinical differences
in those outcomes in those people
so one group has low fruits and
vegetables one group has high fruits and
vegetables
and how long is the study i think it was
eight weeks i'll pull it up
is that long enough to see a detrimental
effect or a positive net benefit
well i think that if you're thinking
about things in terms of oxidative
stress that happens pretty quickly
you would definitely i think begin to
see increased dna damage
we measure it with this marker called
8-hydroxy2-deoxyguanosine lipid
peroxides
inflammation i think you would see it
you start to see it pretty quickly when
you get lower levels of vitamin c
the the higher vitamin c group with more
fruits and vegetables certainly had a
higher level of vitamin c in their blood
but they didn't have any differences in
terms of those markers
so this one is what about the benefits
of vitamin c
in fighting off uh colds and infections
right the um so the interventional
studies with that have generally
failed really yeah yeah but the
consensus wisdom is that like
if you have a virus right take vitamin c
take vitamin c
yeah i'll show you this one so if you go
to the vitamin c folder jamie and then
you go
to the vitamin c from an evolutionary
perspective study
you'll see a list of all the
interventional studies with vitamin c
scroll down to the
table 2.
so one more table down that one
so you'll see these are interventional
studies with vitamin c and
there's an rct there for
the common cold it's a meta-analysis
actually which uh 11
306 participants and there was no effect
on the incidence of the common cold
so this gets into the interesting
conversation about epidemiology and i
know you know about this
the way that epidemiology is so
misleading for us
and if you look at the association of
vitamin c
in the blood there's an association with
better outcomes
but when we do interventional studies we
don't see it
and with in this table you can see no
effect on mortality
no effect on the incidence of the common
cold no effect on cardiovascular events
and essentially no decrease in systolic
blood pressure with intervention
no effect no incidences no effect on the
incidences of the common cold but
what about once someone has a cold i
think
it's like when emergency and all these
different vitamin c
supplements this is what they're always
claiming is that
taking it while you have the cold is
what's going to reduce the
duration of the disease concluded that
vitamin c supplementation has no effect
on the incidence of the common cold
however a modest reduction of symptoms
was consistently found in reviewed
studies
yeah so maybe so so good while you have
it
maybe while you have it so if you have
something then
jack up the dose
yeah vitamin c is a complex one because
there are many things which can lower
vitamin c as well
so metabolic dysfunction decreases
levels of vitamin c in our body so the
playing field is not always level right
okay so if you have a cold your your
vitamin c level is going to be lower
could be lower right or if you have a
baseline of unhealth
something that's been super relevant
with the current covid conversation
yeah if you have a baseline of ill
health or baseline of metabolic
dysfunction sometimes synonymous with
insulin resistance
per a given vitamin c intake there's
lower levels of vitamin c
in the body so if you look at
animal foods like if you eat nose to
tail if you're eating a couple ounces of
liver per day
and some meat per day and other organs
you can get pretty close to 70
milligrams of vitamin c a day which is
basically the rda i think the rda might
be 70 or 90 milligrams of vitamins
this expression nose to tail a lot of
people don't know what we're talking
about
what you're talking about is organ meats
yeah yeah it's eating organ meats
because
most people when they think of eating
animal
products they think of just eating
tissue muscle tissue
episodes of the joe rogan experience are
now free on spotify
that's right they're free from september
1st to december 1st they're going to be
available everywhere but after december
1st they will only be
available on spotify but they will be
free that includes the video the video
will also be there
it'll also be free that's all we're
asking just go download spotify
much love